i'm
shaking proposing today from tiffany
will you marry me we can't go this far
okay ready ready let's kiss
[Applause]
hmm
i've seen you a little bit prior to this
in the past few months but the last time
we were together one-on-one was the
first time we kissed and we were like
13. i was actually 12. yeah
that's so sick technicalities math
i know cameron because we're dating for
a little over three years basically
we're all in in all the same classes and
you're a little weird i'm always weird i
didn't notice he was in my classes for a
while but apparently he noticed my
parents
sent me to this retreat camp
thing through my church like not tying
and climbing trees i was trying to make
a fire i don't know how long i would say
like probably over two hours and then i
saw
someone like i could recognize that she
was like around my age hey come over
here i like really need assistance so
i'm from san francisco but iko's from
new york and i was up here visiting my
uncle i heard there was a porta potty
and so i went
lurking around for the porta potty never
found it i got lost i wasn't really like
supposed to date i had the great idea to
did like a double date first aid is a
double date of the important thing for
me it was that she was there we were
hanging out after the movie just like
chilling in the car
oh man it was so awkward i saw that and
was like this is this is time so i bent
down and she just woke no well i've
never kissed anyone before i have no
idea what i'm doing it's gonna be
terrible
we ended up like making the fire like it
it worked
so we were both like have you had your
first kiss i was like yeah we can we
could be each other's first kisses yeah
whatever and it was like the setting was
right it was already like sort of night
timey very metaphorical we like sparked
a flame what else do you do so yeah that
is weird
we gave each other like three kisses
yeah they were sweaty and like just very
disgusting
but it still felt very magical after i
went in and she backed out i messed it
up
you know wrong time and then i felt bad
because you looked sad i ruined
everything
we can do it we can try again
and then it was very awkward and very
stiff it wouldn't have been right for me
if it hadn't been incredibly awkward
but like we didn't really say goodbye to
each other yeah just like crazy fast
forward i forget what context it was in
but we were both both of us were there
she starts talking about like bear
mountain and then we were just like kept
putting two and two together and we were
like that was definitely both of us we
go to the same school studying
essentially almost the same thing and
like for years after i was kind of like
would think back on i was like a crush
that you knew that like wouldn't
actually happen i've thought about like
my sexuality because i'm from like a
very conservative area this reality
wasn't like very tangible to me having
an experience like that really young is
very freeing yeah i mean definitely made
me re-evaluate just attraction in
general i pictured it being
explosive was that explosive no you fit
it perfectly i think it was awesome the
only like reference i had was movies
so it's just that very like intense kiss
in the rain like that's how i pictured
it like oh that would be
ideal
and then like that didn't really happen
honestly i don't think i would be where
i'm at today if i hadn't like met him
and we started dating because i kept to
myself a lot now i have like a big
engineering job i talk to a bunch of
people and he's always like you got this
you're a
boss lady
it depends on every person so for you
know what worked with us was honestly
pure awkwardness
there's no going back for me i'm here
you can't get rid of me
i feel like it's still very it's like
platonic um it's more just funny and
playful what are your thoughts on
kissing again
i
am totally down to kiss again i'm down
to kiss again rekindle a flame
i hate you
[Music]
i'm excited this will be funny i want to
like pretend to make the fire again okay
you can do that i'll go off and then
come back on oh my gosh this fire come
here
someone's hobbling over
would you happen to have any
marshmallows we can't go this far no
okay okay okay ready ready let's kiss
[Music]
then the fire starts
kissing makes me feel like i'm at home
it's
safe
and i take every opportunity i can to
get her well it's an opportunity right
why are you like people watching so yeah
i know she'll be in my life for
many more years
to come at least i hope i think we
should do this like every seven years
do you guys think we'll get each other's
weddings
whoa i don't want to get married yeah i
don't know about marriage cool that we
agree on that actually but we were just
discussing this morning somebody getting
spiritually married maybe we should get
spiritually married the first kiss means
to me the start of something exciting it
doesn't have to last very long
but if it does
[Laughter]
been a long time coming but i'm
ready to propose to her how long until
it happens uh
30 45 minutes maybe really
do you mind giving us this new paperwork
no i i wrote it on my phone last night
actually so i wrote
since the day i saw you in class i've
had this unshakable feeling drawing
me toward you
i didn't know how to explain it but i
knew it was good a little while ago that
feeling went away i believe it's because
it had served its purpose
because that was the day that i realized
that i can't bear to live my life
without you
so now it's time
to finally ask
tiffany will you marry me
in the end like i wouldn't say i regret
at least not this
we got it good
brought us to where we are in life
and
i don't think we would be the same
people if we regretted that wouldn't
want to be with anyone else
[Applause]
you